the Treasury Department suggestion that
tax cuts will more than pay for
themselves is under close scrutiny the
department projects a revenue gain of
three hundred billion dollars over ten
years but two nonpartisan groups say tax
cuts would add at least a trillion
dollars to the deficit mark Weinberger
is CEO and global chairman of a why
formerly known as Ernst & Young he's
also a former assistant Treasury
secretary on tax policy under president
george w bush and he served on the
Social Security Administration Advisory
Board under President Bill Clinton mark
welcome thanks John the president and
Republicans have sold this as a
middle-class tax cut when you look at
the entire text about all that it does
is this a middle-class tax cut this is a
tax bill that will affect every business
and every individual United States
foreign companies invest in United
States as well John it will in my view
increase investment the United States it
will make the consist amore competitive
allow companies to reinvest in workers
bring that foreign cash back to the
United States and it does provide for
middle-income tax cut by doubling the
standard deduction increasing the child
credit and lowering the brackets but as
a truth and advertising thing mark mark
Sanford who cares a lot about debt and
deficit which we'll get to but
Republican congressman from South
Carolina says this is quote a corporate
tax reduction and restructuring bill
that's what the bills big about nine
billion dollars nine hundred billion
dollars of the 1.5 trillion goes to
individual relief through the
pass-through entities ninety five
percent of businesses in the United
States are pass-throughs and the
individuals about four to five hundred
billion is for corporate relief remember
in addition to the tax cuts for the
corporations there's a lot of tax
increases it's crapped some fifty
credits and deductions it puts new and
provisions in to prevent what they call
base erosion from companies moving
assets and income overseas so yes it dis
allows for the first time interest
deductions for highly leveraged
companies that offset some of the tax
cuts for corporations well the bulk of
the benefits from this tax bill go to
middle-class families I think the belt
benefit will to workers who are going to
be working these companies when the
money comes home we have a Business
Roundtable did a study and it's and the
CEO said that that seventy six percent
would invest more in workers and wages
if this tax bill were to pass eighty one
percent said that they would invest in
capital equipment which would make
workers more productive which is what we
need in this country
any evidence that that has happened in
the past what's hard to know so in 2001
we did as you know when I worked for
President Bush we did a tax cut and in
2001 we had a 1% growth rate by 2002 it
was a 1.8 percent 2003 was 2.8 1% came
from the tax cuts what percent came from
just growth in the economy you don't
know in that case it wasn't a business
tax cut and it was phased in this is
immediate expensing of equipment it is
immediate drop to 20 percent corporate
tax rate it is allowing those companies
to bring back that cash overseas I think
it's clear that money will come back to
the United States in some way or form
yes mark the question was asking is
there any evidence that those companies
will then reinvest that in workers to
the workers only what the CEOs are
telling us I mean you don't know because
you know listen it's not going to create
new demand that doesn't exist today so
it will it has to when a US company gets
a tax cut it can only do three things
with it
it could either invest in new plant
equipment it could either paid wakers
more workers more money or increased
increase hiring or it could pay the
money back to Cheryl do anything else I
think you're one of the smartest a lot
on this issue and you've worked for
Democrats and Republicans but that's a
pretty big we don't know whether
corporations are gonna pass that
especially if you're going to add 1.5
trillion dollars to the day what we do
know and are a Democrat some Republicans
recognize that the US business system is
so anti-competitive there's been we
talked about inversions in the what you
know and it'll mess last many years
about companies moving their
headquarters overseas what wasn't talked
about is the large number of companies
that were acquired by foreign companies
that no longer in the United States it's
going to arrest that because now it's
going to make the US a place where the
companies will want to invest that's a
good thing for workers it's a good thing
for business today US multinationals
employ 25 million people 50 million in
the supply chain and 75 percent of the
value add 75 percent of the Rd and two
thirds of the workers are where
companies headquartered you want those
businesses to be the United States
wanted to be a strong economic
environment there are great to have you
here it's always a pleasure now and by
the way you talk fast too you get so
much in thank you thanks for being here
here's good TV